[موسيقى]
كان هذا احد السيناريوهات التي تخشاها
الجيوش النظاميه في حرب المدن ما تسمى
بمعضلة
الاشتباك مع الاهداف البعيده في ارض
مفتوحه وعندما تدخل المدينه يصبح مجال
الرؤيه محدودا وبحاجه الى قوات المشاه
لدعمها لكن المباني تسمح للمدافع
بالاختباء والاستفاده من الزوايا العمياء
للدبابه وحتى ان كانت مدعومه بكاميرات
واجهزه رسد فللم فع في المدينه قدره على
الاقتراب من المدرعه الى الدرجه التي لا
تستطيع فيها الدفاعات العمل من مسافه
قريبه فلو اقترب المهاجم على سبيل المثال
من دبابه بها مضاد للقذائف فان النظام لن
يتمكن على الاغلب من صد القذيفه المطلقه
من المسافه القريبه لقصر زمن الاستجابه
كما يمكن لمستهدفات
مهاجمتها داخل المدينه من زوايا عده
الاعلى او الاسفل والاقتراب منها وهو ما
لا تتيحه المساحات المفتوحه لذلك تحتاج
الدبابه الى قوات المشاه لدعمها بتطهير
المربعات ومن ثم التقدم وهنا تبرز مشكله
للقوات المدافعه فالقوات المهاجمه قد تملك
اجهزه متقدمه كمعدات الرؤيه الليليه
وامكانيات الكشف عن المدافعين بالحساسات
والرادارات اضافه الى قوه ناريه كبيره
فمثلا قد يفضل قوات المشاه تسويه البناء
بالارض باستخدام مدفع الدبابه بدلا من
الاشتباك المباشر مع المقاتلين داخل
البناء
وهنا تبرز معضله اخرى للمهاجمين فالرخام
يلعب دورا افضل في اعاقه تقدم الاليات من
الابنيه حسب الخبراء فهو يسمح بوجود فجوات
لاختباء المدافعين وليس له شكل هندسي
منتظم كالابن يسمح لقوات المشاه بتمشيطه
بشكل مدروس وسيعرض سير المدرعات او الحاجه
للاخلاء او نقل مصابي الجيش المهاجم لذلك
تعتبر حرب المدن مبطله لتكنولوجيا الجيوش
المتقدمه وتعطي الدفاع افضليه المباغته
على القوات النظاميه المقتحمه